PAUL: I have been a bit worried
about your little peanut
head in winter.
And with it coming
up to Thanksgiving,
I thought, well, I'm
thankful for Jake.
So I got you a present.
I bought you a hat.
JAKE: I have a hat.
Oh my word.
PAUL: It's both on
brand for Thanksgiving.
JAKE: It's all I
hoped for and more.
What do I do with these?
They're going to chafe.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL: The network people for a
long time have had all the fun.
And now it's the runtime time.
We've got a new API.
It's the web smoothness API.
JAKE: The web smoothness API?
Please tell me it's
just web smoothness true
and then the web is smooth.
PAUL: Yes.
Now, the problem with that name
kind of came up in the feedback
from other vendors.
And they said no,
actually, it isn't that.
Because it's about
measuring information.
It's not about whether you're
going to switch on smoothness.
And it does sound
like that, doesn't it?
So it's actually been renamed
to the frame timing API.
JAKE: So it's going
to give us some
of what we have for the
network [? tiny ?] API
but for rendering?
PAUL: Yeah, pretty much.
So I think most people
are used to the idea
that they use something
like DevTools Timeline.
They get all the records, like
what's your frames per second,
but that only applies to the
machine they've got, right--
their desktop
machine, their phone,
whatever they've got on
their desk or in their lab.
This is about doing it
at like an API level,
so you can do it
out in the wild.
So all your users,
you could, in theory,
measure your transitions, your
animations, your scrolling,
all those things, and start
to get a lot more data
about what's going on in
your main thread, what's
going on in your
compositor thread.
JAKE: So you could use
this to, say, find out--
in combination with
the user agent string--
find out on a particular device
that you've never even tested
before, maybe you've
never heard of before,
but you have a major
performance problem there.
PAUL: You may not even do
it through the UA string.
Because you can collect these
bits of information and beacon
them back to analytics
or something like that.
And it will do all that hard
work of what device it was,
or where it was in the
world, and all those things.
And you could just
beacon back events
and say, well, look, I think
it was 60 frames a second.
And then you could
slice the data however
make sense to you, really.
JAKE: So how can
I tie these events
back to the elements that
are causing the problem?
Does it tell me
which element has
been drawn, which
element's been composited?
PAUL: Nope.
So the API is actually
quite low-level, I suppose.
And it doesn't say
what was going on,
because the browser
doesn't really
know ahead of time
what makes sense.
So it just kind of goes, here's
what the main thread was doing.
Here's what the compositor
thread was doing.
And you're responsible for
marking those areas yourself.
And the spec itself is
still in flux, right?
So there's a lot of
opportunity for developers
and other vendors
to kind of come
back and bike shed it
until we get to something
we think is great.
But at this point,
hopefully, there's
enough base information
in there and in the API
that people can
start using it, start
pulling data from the works.
We've heard so many
times, it's so hard.
I do the measurement
in my own machine,
but I don't know
if I've actually
got runtime problems
out in the wild.
I know this for network
because I've got webpage tests.
I've got all these other APIs.
So this is the first API
we should get for this.
It's very exciting.
JAKE: Do you give them
feedback to the stuff?
Where is it?
Is it W3, is it--
PAUL: W3.
There's a W3C repo/frame-timing
and all the issues on there
and there's an explainer doc and
the latest draft of the specs.
So, well worth checking out.
JAKE: Real world
analytics for rendering.
PAUL: Woo-hoo!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAKE: So it's been
conference season.
So I've been doing
a lot of traveling.
And so you've got your
suitcase full of clean clothes.
As the week goes on,
they become soiled
by your personal wearing.
PAUL: They become soiled.
Maybe time to go
and see somebody.
JAKE: There's just
general personal soilage.
PAUL: Oh.
Let's move on.
JAKE: So we were speaking
about getting undressed.
You do the flick off
[WHISTLES], catch.
Where did it go?
PAUL: Oh.
Into the suitcase?
JAKE: Not with
your clean clothes.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JAKE: You monster.
PAUL: No, you unpack
them like a grown-up
and you put them in the drawers.
JAKE: They're folded--
in the drawers?
That's where stuff
gets forgotten.
Your clothes, all nicely folded
already, stay in the suitcase.
So I have a solution.
I take with me a bin bag.
And that is where
the dirty clothes go.
And this has many
advantages, right?
Because you put them in there.
It's a separate
place for them to go.
Keeps them separate
from the clean clothes,
which are all nicely folded
in the suitcase still.
And it also locks
the freshness in.
But because it's
airtight, which is a plus,
at the end of the week
it becomes negative.
Because you need
to pack that away.
And in order to get it
back in the suitcase,
you need to lose the excess air.
PAUL: No.
JAKE: And you go for
a process that I've
come to know as stinky bagpipes.
[MAKES BAGPIPE SOUND]
PAUL: [MAKES BAGPIPE SOUND]
JAKE: You get to
play a sad, sad song.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAKE: OK, Paul.
I want to talk to you
about font rendering.
PAUL: Ooh.